[Music]
hi
my name's sean i'm a product manager at
rstudio
as a product manager i get to talk to
data science teams
both small and large all over the world
and unfortunately
in interacting with these teams we often
hear
that they're confronted by a false
choice to either pick
r or python this choice might occur
when they're writing a job description
to hire a new data scientist
it might occur when they're trying to
decide
what to learn as individuals who want to
upskill themselves
or it might occur when they're
interacting with i.t asking for
resources to support a project
so why do teams face this false choice
do we really need to pick
between one language or another well the
answer is no and today we're going to
talk about why
we're going to look at some of the
common myths that lead to this choice
how to debunk those myths and ultimately
how data science teams can be most
effective
when they choose to use r and python
together
now to set some context imagine you're a
craftsman
someone who is handy and builds things
as a craftsman you'd probably be
familiar with screwdrivers
i mean who hasn't used a screwdriver to
put something together
and you might be aware that screwdrivers
come in a variety of different shapes
and forms
you can have a flat head screwdriver a
star bit
a phillips head and each of these
screwdrivers
is designed to serve a specific purpose
now imagine as a craftsman if you were
told that you have to choose for the
rest of your career
between using one type of screwdriver or
another
you'd probably look at that person and
say that's crazy there's no way i can
practically make this choice
for some projects i'm going to need a
flathead for other projects i'll need a
phillips
doesn't make sense for me to pick one
screwdriver to use for the rest of my
career
instead what you might do as a craftsman
is to say i want to opt in to using
a smarter tool a tool that's going to be
more powerful
and allow me to take advantage of all
these different
bits that are out there specifically as
a
craftsman you might be interested in
something like a drill
a tool that regardless of what bit
you're going to need for a project
allows you to work faster and to
accomplish more
and allows you to work in an easier
fashion
so craftsmen have this drill what about
data science teams
well i believe as data scientists we
should refuse
that same false choice between r and
python in other languages
just as the craftsman refuses to pick
one type of screwdriver
instead we should work alongside of
folks in i.t
and the leaders of our teams to build
something like a drill
something that regardless of what
language we use is going to give us the
power
to accomplish our projects faster and
easier
so what is that drill for data science
we'll take a look at that in a second
but first i want to address
some of these common objections that
you'll hear people that say
no no no there's no such thing as a
drill for data science
we have to pick a single language or a
single
screwdriver so where do these objections
come from what's the biggest
objection that data science teams face
well the first one
is this belief that if we are to support
more than one
language we'll end up doing a lot of
duplicate
duplicative work so for example if i
were a team that wanted to use
r and python i t might be worried that
now i have two
times the amount of work to do instead
of supporting one language
i now have to support two that means
twice the number of installs
twice the number of support tickets
twice the money spent
on it resources and luckily
this line of thinking simply isn't
accurate and the reason for that is
because
regardless of what language you use
the core things that it needs to support
are the same
things like computation logs
authentication
security data access these provide a
common core
that drill that we can invest in
regardless of which drill bit which
language
we end up using so i want to show you
some of those tools that we've worked on
at our studio
to make that type of underlying
investment that core
of data science infrastructure
accessible
so the first thing i want to take a look
at is in the development space when
we're data scientists
going to write code in either our python
often what we want is to choose an
editor that's purpose built for one of
those languages
so in r that might be the r studio ide
in python that might be something like a
jupiter notebook
or more recently jupiter labs or perhaps
i want to use a full-fledged development
environment like vs code
now it might be thinking oh no that
means we have to support
all these different editors all these
different environments but luckily
that's not true
with tools like rstudio server pro you
can install
a single infrastructure that supports
those different editors
and so what you're seeing on the screen
here is the home page of our studio
server when a data scientist enters
through that common front door
they're able to pick the different
editors that they might want to use for
a certain project
so it only has to stand up one server
environment they only have to do one set
of configuration
they only have to supply data access to
one common entry point
but the data scientist is still able to
use whatever editor makes the most sense
for their project
you'll also see here that we're taking
advantage of cloud
native tools like kubernetes to provide
elastic scale
and a docker back end to provide
explicitly
those dependencies that we might need
for a project so what this all amounts
to is that in development
we're able to get to our first line of
code really quickly regardless of what
language that line of code is written in
without doubling the i.t headaches now
that's development
what about production what about when it
comes time to
create these different artifacts and
share those with others
well luckily the same concept applies so
at our studio what that looks like
is a tool like rstudio connect so our
studio connect
allows you to deploy a wide variety of
beta artifacts regardless of what
language
they're written in so for web
applications in
r that might be something like shiny for
web applications in python that might be
something like dash
streamlit or bokeh but regardless of
which of those
engines you choose to use our studio
connect allows you
to quickly deploy them onto a web server
so that you get a url that you can share
with others
and connect takes care of things like
authentication security
logging and scale similarly
if you wanted to create an api so you
have a model that you want to expose to
other services
well that exposure might take place in r
through a package like plumber
or might take place in python through a
tool like flask
but either way connect provides that
common core
infrastructure that drill finally the
same thing applies
for automated reporting so in the python
side that might be jupiter notebooks
on the r side it might be something like
our markdown regardless
again we're able to deploy those things
to connect and connect can handle things
like
scheduling those notebooks to be
re-rendered on a regular basis
emailing stakeholders with the new
results and even
customizing those emails so that you can
send exactly what you need
to a stakeholder's inbox regardless of
what language you're using for a project
and again it's only setting up this
infrastructure once
they're not doubling their work just
because you're
multiplying by five or ten fold the
number of different data products that
you can use
as a data scientist that flexibility is
key
when it comes to communicate your work
getting buy into the modeling that
you're doing
or working alongside of a domain expert
in real time in a meeting
you need to have the flexibility to use
all these different tools
to be an effective data science team and
so that's
what we're setting out to do is to build
products
build those drills that allow you
regardless of drill bit
to effectively communicate your work and
so
because this is so important because it
is the most common myth
i want to spend just a little bit more
time
looking at that common core and so this
diagram hopefully shows you what i've
been talking about
where we have these layers that are
going to be the same
regardless of what language we're using
so those layers
are things like common authentication
things like
logging things like scaling and then the
final layer the choice of r or python
is ultimately a last mile effort so
we're not
multiplying our work by two we're
actually only
changing that final top piece now i
showed you our studio server pro and our
stereo connect is one way to implement
this drill
but teams can implement the drill in
other ways as well
for example some organizations will use
a cloud provider
some organizations will use something
like docker
regardless the key concept is that you
build
those common paradigms that your data
scientist regardless of
language or package is going to be able
to take advantage of
and once you debunk that myth that
more languages mean more problems you're
well on your way
to those multiplicative efforts to
avoiding that false choice
and having a lot more options to build
what you need to build to get the job
done
so that's that first myth hopefully now
debunked let's talk about
a second one which is that multilingual
teams can't collaborate
imagine you are a data science team
leader
and you have three or four data
scientists on your team
that have built out something really
awesome in python
in fact i was speaking to a data
scientist data science team leader named
wayne recently
who was exactly in this situation but he
needed to hire someone new
you know his context was a marketing
project he really wanted to hire someone
with
marketing domain knowledge but
unfortunately he couldn't find that
candidate who had both the python
expertise
and the marketing background but he did
know a few people who had strong
marketing chops
and knew a little bit of r is he
presented with a false choice here
i think so because it turns out that
even if your code base is mostly in
python
you can bring someone who has a
background in r
up to speed really quickly and again it
comes down to having those right tools
a common drill bit to allow for that
type of inter-team
collaboration and so i want to quickly
show you what investments we've made in
our studio
to make that type of collaboration
possible
so what we're looking at here is the
rstudio ide
and the new version of the ide has a
what you see is what you mean
editor for our markdown and inside of
that editor
you're able to incorporate both r and
python code chunks
so here you're looking at python code
that we're able to run
but that code takes advantage of objects
coming from
r see the r.cars object
so once we have that python code
executed it's actually going to write
objects back into
the environment that we can see in the
ide so in the environment pane and
objects floor
we can view that pandas data frame we
created and once we're happy with the
result that we have in python
we can use the what you see is what you
mean editor to insert an
r code chunk that takes advantage of
that python data frame
so just like we used the r object in
python we can use the python object in
r and create a plot with ggplot2 of that
python data
now this interoperability extends beyond
our markdown
through the reticulate package so here
we have a shiny application
that's going to take a python function
and actually
source it and make it available to the r
engine without any conversion
it's pretty magical we can then call
that python function inside of our shiny
app
and that allows us to build something
like this which is a shiny application
where the front end all the input and
controls
are driven by shiny but the back end
simulation is occurring
in those python functions so we're able
as a multilingual team
to really glue these two things together
whether we're bilingual or not
we can take advantage of a code base
written in either language
to achieve a really unique outcome and
that's what
debunking these false choices is all
about it's finding ways
to combine the strengths the best of
both languages
as well as the best of our team to come
together
to create something faster and easier
than we could if we were in isolated
silos with either language
and that leads me to my final point
which is that
we need as data scientists to optimize
for people
not for tools well what do i mean by
that well think about the story of
wayne trying to hire as it turned out
her name was vicky
a data scientist coming from the r space
instead of the python background
because wayne was able to set aside the
distinction in tools
he could come up with a data science
team that together was more effective
than if he had limited his job criteria
to only people that knew python
and so we see that story play out time
and time again
at the end of the day when we talk to
data science team leaders
their most important asset and their
most expensive
isn't a particular tool or platform it's
the data scientists that they're hiring
to solve complex problems
another way one of the big reasons
organizations invest in data science in
the first place
is because black box solutions like
tableau or power bi
simply don't meet the needs of the rich
complex
real world problems that they're facing
so why
would it make any sense for those same
data science teams
that have recognized they need the
flexibility and power of code to achieve
outcomes
to then sabotage themselves by limiting
themselves to only one language
it simply doesn't it's a false choice
and so today
my final plea is to pick the people
that will make your data science team
effective and then supply them with what
they need
don't make people subservient to tools
it should be the other way around
allow data science teams to pick
whatever language or tool is going to be
most effective
and to help you do that at our studio
we've invested in building out drills
so that regardless of what drill bit you
need you can effectively build something
faster
and easier thank you so much for your
time and i look forward to your
[Music]
questions
you